you are absolutely amused amazing in
this film here kickass in this film and
especially when you come out in that
two-piece you look phenomenal in this
movie did you train extra hard for
Mission Impossible I did actually I was
filming a crown at the same time and
coming to Paris and I knew that you know
the script was evolving all the time so
we weren't sure how many stunts would be
involved in and I just thought even if
it's just one I can't join the Tom
Cruise maybe I can't do Mission
Impossible movie without being
physically able to at least keep out at
least five metres behind him in and
running in a running race running the
other way yeah yeah yeah so yeah it was
really it was it was it was part of the
the journey in a sense so yeah I did I
did train really hard and hated it to
begin with because I was so unfit and
then and then I loved it by their
absolute love to do I usually you may
run a marathon is that right
I've said it in the field yeah you
probably beat meets with it no I sweat a
lot too when I'm running but you know
this movie is absolutely amazing that
first time when you met Tom Cruise and
he wanted to work with you
what was that initial reaction for you I
just said um thank you i dub - cuz he
kind of shook my hand he was like Jonah
come and join us and I was like yeah I
mean I can't say no so yeah it was it
was it was quite surreal but um you know
I instantly knew it would be a
completely different journey and I've
never done a kind of actually movie
before this kind of in any way so it was
just a new experience for me you're good
at action you should go that's it that's
a pretty good trick to do when you're
working with Tom did he give any because
not a pep talk but give you a
conversation of how the the film is made
and give you an idea what you're what to
expect from Mission Impossible six uh
yeah I mean I think him and Chris worked
to get on the last one so they were very
very close and they compete trusted each
other which meant that you know a lot of
the a lot of the scenes what we've been
worked out and it's changing and you
know the the plot lines were changing so
you didn't really what you had to do was
just find your character
all I knew is I need to find an essence
of who she was and as somebody that was
technically a body and you know it's
runs as kind of criminal network and
she's just in the first third of the
movie and just the Paris section yeah I
knew that her presence would have to be
slightly mysterious and really just odd
and so we wanted that sort of disarming
presence and that was something we
worked on which was quite hard for me
actually because I was playing Margaret
and kind of like putting everything out
right emotionally you know on the
surface and then to her like wind it
back in and not show anything was really
hard for me and but also just the
journey of you know taking a leap of
faith and just going with the movie and
you know doing what's thrown at you and
yeah I thought I'm sure all the actors
would say that it was a sort of it's a
very kind of a different experience to
from where array yeah they take you
different did Tom Cruise ever talk about
the crown on on set does he watch the
show he did yeah he loved it I know that
was quite real Winnie just nothing yeah
uh music you love the you know yeah I
just loved everybody in it yeah it was
really yeah I takes Peter Morgan being
like hum Tom's a fan so yeah that was a
surreal moment you know when you talk
about that you moving into action I
understand they're gonna be working with
Dwayne the rock Johnson on Fast and the
Furious spin-off it seems like you're on
this incredible adventure you you wanna
BAFTA for Best Supporting Actress are
you living your best life right now in
your career yeah the movie isn't kaboom
yes if it happened yes yeah the river
yeah I mean this is great it's just I
mean for me I I fell after Margaret um
you know I'm there was never sort of one
particular genre that I wanted to go
down but I always felt that after her
and playing a woman and that kind of
protagonist role where the men are in
relationship it felt really important
that no matter what the genre that if
you're representing it as a woman it's
really important now to to make sure
that the women are as fierce as the men
if not fiercer and and from what I know
of that project is that she is
absolutely the boss of all of them and
takes
charge of all of them and is that is the
fiercest by far and I think that's
really important because there are a lot
of girls that go and see those kind of
movies and the girls that go and see
those kind of movies see them the men do
all the stuff and that's not fair
so I think it's really important to to
be representing on screen to show that
those girls you know that they have just
as much as capability if not more than
their counterparts you know I love the
fact that you're talking about
empowering women and when there were
things that were written in the tabloids
you shut it down
when things happened were you shocked by
the change in your I guess your life
when that happened the the time about
about Tommy yeah yeah it was so silly
which is so good about it Tommy I never
even talked about it um you know because
I'm sure he wouldn't even know you know
he doesn't I'm sure suffer gets written
all the time and that level of Fame and
he obviously doesn't pay attention yeah
but um it was just funny I I think
that's the first story came out when I
hadn't even met him we hadn't started
filming and I was apparently getting
married last news to me I've got a ring
you know I haven't met my future husband
yet so no it was just ridiculous and
I've had a boyfriend for year so it was
all bit silly really but you know and
just go it for me it was actually great
because um you realize that you just
can't believe anything that you read so
anything that I see about anybody now I
just completely discount straight away
because it's just to sell papers and
yeah you know give someone something to
read in the morning right I know that
was a bit funny it what really was yeah
extreme now when he broke his ankle and
it was downtime for pretty much the cast
and crew did you do anything exciting or
did you just kind of focus on your work
I had to go do the pressed off the crown
so we're in Australia and very rarely oh
yes I actually went directly and did
that um so it's kind of you know it was
well it fit admit that fitting perfectly
and Rebecca had a baby you know there's
lots of lovely things to come out of it
including I know that you know the
movies still open on time and I think
actually gave Chris a real opportunity
to get in the edit and see what was
working
it's all in the edit this movie I'm sure
because like those sequences and because
none that most of it isn't CGI yeah
hardly any of it is putting all together
is such a I imagine you know a really
intense process so yeah in the end it
all worked out fine and Tom McCullar
than two minutes like a like a miracle
and I was amazed and mi7 in the
conversation now I don't know I mean
they're the romantic connection to Ethan
Hunt never Widow the Wiz oh I know
happen you never know like Simon
appeared in a few of them and yeah
Michelle's back and say yeah you just
don't know you look forward to doing it
again well I mean I'd love to anytime
you set up a character and you start
beginning to explore it and you know it
was just a sort of just a few scenes to
really find that person yeah to kind of
have the the yeah the scope to come and
go on a journey with with someone that
you really made it's really fun I loved
it with doing two seasons at the crown
so yeah why not today's emmy nominations
oh I think it is the crowds gonna be
nominated and was like you're gonna be
nominated if you were nominated would
that be an exciting moment for you you
know what on that it would but on that
job it was just the happiest time in my
life and so even with the BAFTA I I just
I couldn't believe it happened when it
did the nomination but let alone winning
and I it I had such a beautiful time in
my life on that job and with that
character I just felt so so lucky and
totally blessed and so to anything else
other than that is just like is is
overwhelming to me because I do I would
never ask or need for anything more than
that experience so yeah finally when you
watch this movie what was your reaction
I couldn't breathe the most good thing
about yeah and they fought out the plane
and that and the bathroom for me there's
so many moments go I actually you know I
was on on that set and I still don't
know how they executed it in real life I
just I can't work it out without having
someone a computer painted him you know
to actually everybody did it it was just
quite incredible I can't wait to see
what you do next Vanessa another
your movie maybe another romance I don't
know what it is but everything you do is
so great oh one more question
make a Merkel row uh are you excited
about her being part of the royal family
yes yes I think they look so in love and
so wonderful everyone was asked us in
the crowd because they think we're like
an authority on how she or how he feels
but almost I think she feels wonderful
and happy but of course you know that's
just what it looks like and so you know
it's great that she's been divorced but
she was allowed to marry the person that
she loved and in the way that you know
Margaret wasn't so thank you sorry I
just think yeah I'd be when I may be in
- yeah she's yeah and I'm a fan of first
- she's she's amazing